two years and 44 billion dollars later
thanks to Elon Musk we now have proof
that Libs at Twitter knowingly played a
major role in rigging the 2020
presidential election for Joe Biden
journalist Matt Tybee broke the news
which revealed corruption so egregious
that President Trump is demanding
immediate reinstatement as president
even if it means the quote termination
of constitutional rules and the cherry
on top of the whole story is the
reaction of the journalists who are
Furious
not at the corruption of our political
system
but it Matt Tybee for exposing the
corruption I'm Michael Knowles as the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from Joshua
Anderson who says Alex Jones saying I'm
in the Twilight Zone right now was Peak
comedy it truly was to have Alex Jones
sitting there thinking oh guys don't you
think you're going a little bit far on
this
um hold on I just uh was a shocking
thing I've never seen this happen before
and it was uh jolting jarring and in in
some ways delightful now when you want
to delight yourself uh at home with the
family out by the grill you got to check
out good ranchers right now head on over
to goodranchers.com use code Knowles a
hard year on the economy means that
essential practical gifts are going to
be in high demand this year give the
most essential gift of all America's
best meat and seafood from good Ranchers
with discounts on orders of five boxes
or more you can save on gifts for the
whole family
when you give a box of good ranchers
you're giving them a true Steakhouse
experience with 100 American USDA prime
and upper Choice cuts of beef chicken
seafood other meat delivery companies
and even your local grocery stores
import lower Quality Meat from overseas
do not give your friends and family less
than America's best this year not sure
what to order good ranchers now offers
gift cards so you can let your friends
and family members choose for it
themselves or give the gift of a
subscription
and you can inflation proof someone's
meat budget go to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles kwles at checkout to get 35
off your gift that is goodrancers.com
code Knowles for 35 off good ranchers
American Meat delivered Twitter gate I'm
sure you have seen the headlines I'm
sure you have seen a ton of spin most
people have not taken the time to
actually read through the reporting of
the story because it's very very long
and somewhat intricate I won't bore you
with all of the details I will give you
the highlights though because this is at
least as corrupt
as we all thought it was and in some
ways it seems much more so
Twitter
was conspiring
with the libs
to rig the platform which is in many
ways the new Public Square for the libs
and against the Republicans
which is a big deal because we at least
notionally have a self-governing
republic so whoever controls the Public
Square controls the political order
because the way the political order
works is that we all persuade one
another of how we want to live in the
Public Square so Twitter is not just
some tech platform it's not just some
app that we do scroll on Twitter
represents
well it represents the American
political order it represents the way
that we speak to one another and
persuade one another and Twitter
colluded with the libs to rig it and
exclude the conservatives Matt taibi is
a liberal journalist he's a guy who's
got bylines and all sorts of lib Outlets
but he's become disillusioned with some
of the liberal journalists in recent
years and so he's the guy that Elon
seems to have picked to give this story
to and he says Hey here are the docs run
with it Matt Tybee do your thing so we
see from the very beginning that the
Biden team by 2020 was regularly
requesting that Twitter takedown tweets
that they didn't like
so they would just send emails in and
say hey there's more to review from the
Biden team we don't like this tweet we
don't like that tweet we don't like this
tweet we don't like that tweet and it
just random accounts sometimes
politically minded accounts sometimes
the accounts of of regular
actors Hollywood celebrities James Woods
in particular was targeted so the the
actor James Woods you know one of the
greatest readers of all time he had his
account targeted
buy the DNC they said an additional
report from the DNC take down the stupid
James Woods tweet James Woods is now
threatening to sue over this uh but but
you see why would they go after James
Woods or other people like that because
they had huge accounts and the those
accounts were going after the Biden team
so they say take it down okay now how
how were the takedowns being done
the Republicans would sometimes request
to take things down as well the problem
is there was no neutral system there was
no formal system at all for this to take
place it was just kind of based on who
you know so if you knew somebody at
Twitter you could email them and say hey
Uncle Joe doesn't really like that tweet
let's get rid of it okay hey I don't
like what James Woods said take that
down and they would do it meanwhile the
Republicans say hey guys come on you're
we're getting death threats over here
people take down this tweet but it would
be like howling into the wind because
nobody at Twitter likes the Republicans
and you can see this based on the
political donations of the people at
Twitter if you look at open Secrets the
donations are just all to Democrats in
the 2022 cycle the donations from
Twitter to Democrats came to 166
thousand dollars the donations from
Twitter to Republicans 451.
not 451 451 dollars that means that the
percentage to Dems was 99.73 percent
2020 cycle 98.47 percent of donations to
Democrats the 2018 cycle 96.38 of
donations to Democrats so not only were
the were the Twitter employees
statistically all giving to Democrats
but or all of the donations we're going
to Democrats but it was actually getting
worse over time it was skewing even more
toward the Democrats over time so no
surprise that the Republicans couldn't
couldn't get the post that they wanted
taking down Democrats almost always did
then you get to the hunter Biden laptop
story so this was a story broken by the
New York Post that they found this
laptop from Hunter Biden that had a ton
of evidence of crimes
not just drug crimes not just sex crimes
being committed by Hunter Biden but
potential political and financial crimes
being committed by Hunter Biden on
behalf of the Biden family trading on
Joe Biden's name while Joe Biden was the
point man to Ukraine for instance
scoring crooked deals in Ukraine trading
on the Biden name while Biden was
serving at the highest levels of the
government to get money out of China
getting meetings arranged between
between these extremely corrupt actors
all around the world and Joe Biden
Hunters the Nexus of that what happens
Twitter says you can't share this story
not only does Twitter say you can't post
the story publicly and then Facebook and
Google followed suit but they say you
couldn't even privately message The
Story So this this step
which says you can't even privately
message something was previously a
mechanism reserved only for child
pornography and it's true actually that
on Hunter Biden's laptop there was it
would appear to be some evidence of
pornography where the girls didn't
totally look 18. but that's that's not
the point here we're not talking about
the actual contents of underbody's
laptop we're talking about a story in
the New York Post so obviously there's
no child pornography in the story they
just went as far as they possibly could
they said this material is unsafe so now
we're going to have a new category it's
a category of content that is so
dangerous that involves child
pornography or something that threatens
the Biden campaign that's it that's that
is now the most extreme category on
Twitter the executives almost
immediately start start raising
questions about this the public policy
executive Carolyn Strom sends an email
out to to several people on the team
saying uh hey guys
are you sure about this are you sure are
we sure that this is this is really
something that that should be banned
from the public platform and such that
you can't privately message it and what
Tybee found out is there was a big
tension between the communications and
policy teams which had basically no
control over moderation and the safety
and Trust teams and those were the ones
who were censoring everybody and
ultimately who would even censor the
duly elected sitting president of the
United States that the next claim that
was made by these guys is that it was a
hacked material so because okay forget
about yeah it's obviously not child
pornography but it's very possibly
hacked materials and so we can't allow
that to be uh spread all around the the
internet again this doesn't hold up at
all
you're seeing uh you're seeing messages
from these top exact saying are you sure
does this is this really going to to
hold up it doesn't really make a lot of
sense to us then the crazy part is Jack
Dorsey was the CEO of Twitter apparently
had no idea what was going on he was not
the guy who made the call to censor the
hunter Biden story he he was I think
away from the office at this point so
that call was made by the former head of
legal policy and Trust Vijaya Gaddy who
Elon Musk nuked from Orbit on his first
day in office everybody knew that this
was messed up this is I think the
biggest Revelation from the Twitter
internal emails is we've just been
gaslit this whole time and Twitter and
big Tech they say no of course this is
totally fine this isn't keeping with our
policy there's nothing wrong here deny
till you die deny till you die you look
at those internal emails there there is
a ton of controversy hearing people are
saying gosh this is really bad we have
screwed up it's not going to hold up but
we can't back away now we've got to
stand firm you see the former trust and
safety chief of Twitter yoel Roth who is
getting into these exchanges with Vijaya
Gaddy and all these people and then you
got a Communications official Trenton
Kennedy at Twitter who says I'm
struggling to understand the policy
basis for marking this is unsafe and
then the the other team basically says
well just shut up and deal with it
everybody knew it there was even a
Democrat there was only one Democrat but
there was a Democrat member of Congress
who knew that this was a big deal
that was Ro Kana who writes to Vijaya
Gaddy the this lady who's who's taking
all the steps to ban people and uh
ultimately would ban Donald Trump and
says hope you're well Vijaya this seems
a violation of the First Amendment
principles if there is a hack of
classified information or other
information that could expose a serious
War crime and the New York Times to
publish it I think the New York Times
should have that right a journalist
should not be held accountable for the
illegal actions of the source unless
they actively aided the hack so you've
got this what this lone Democrat out
there saying guys what about the First
Amendment even if this were hacked
material which it's not by the way still
you can't just ban it from from being
circulated by the way you allow the
publication of all sorts of Republican
hacked material material that that was
hacked that does not bode well for
Republicans on your platform it just
this doesn't hold up and yet even the
Democrat admitting it
so then what happens
then what happens what happens is
the journalists
take stock of their failures right the
journalists this took two years this
shouldn't have taken two years the
journalists they come together right and
they say gosh we did not investigate
this huge abuse of power we gosh we did
not we did not speak truth to power as
we are supposed to do and and they they
looked inside themselves and they were
very introspective and just kidding they
didn't say that at all they actually
just kept Shilling on behalf of the
Democrats and they went after Matt tyvee
you've got all these liberal journalists
turning on their liberal journalist
friend for doing the job of a journalist
or at least the ideal job of a
journalist in reality journalists are
pretty much just propagandists for a
particular point of view they're not
neutral they're not merely speaking
truth to power that has never been the
case ever in the whole history of
Journalism
but with the exception of maybe some
independent people who have their own
acts to grind usually as well but you
see the the complete mask fall down by
the liberal journals in reaction to Matt
Tybee who say hey wait a second
you're not just supposed to expose the
real power structures now when you want
to make yourself more powerful when you
want to stop being such a slob and a
blob and a doom scrolling loser you've
got
to check out Exodus 90. right now head
on over to exodus90.com Knowles men is
it time to stop the Mindless Doom
scrolling time to finally gain that
higher quality of life you know that
you're missing out on if this sounds
familiar then on January 9th join
thousands of men all over the world to
embark on a 90-day journey together in
search of a better life it's called
Exodus 90. it was built to help men
enjoy the freedom of becoming who they
were truly made to be
Exodus 90 guides you in removing the
attachments that are holding you back
from a better life and it actually works
independent research shows that Exodus
90 men report considerable shifts after
the 90 days including stronger
satisfaction rates in their marriages
more meaningful prayer lives and
dramatic decreases in time spent on
their phones for the past seven years
Exodus has helped more than sixty
thousand men build a road map for living
with virtue in a culture that offers far
too many paths to self-destruction so is
it time for your Exodus we start January
9th find resources to prepare for Exodus
at exodus90.com Knowles that is
exodus90.com Knowles
Ali he is a liberal journalist very
prominent on Twitter he's been at all
sorts of outlets he says Matt Tybee What
a Sad disgraceful downfall I swear kids
he did good work back in the day
should be a cautionary tale for everyone
selling your soul for the richest white
nationalist on Earth
well he'll eat well for the rest of his
life I guess but is it worth it
and I I read that and I actually didn't
get it at first I said the richest White
National who is the richest white
nationalist I realize he's referring to
Elon Musk
is he
is Elon Musk a white nationalist
I guess he's white although he is an
African-American so that complicates
things
I guess he's white is Elon Musk even a
nationalist
I don't know that he's a nationalist
I see I see no evidence that he's a
nationalist and it made me realize the
term white nationalism that's just the
new meaningless phrase that the libs
throw around it's just the new racism
they the libs used to call everyone that
they didn't like racist and if that the
word racist ever had any meaning it
certainly doesn't anymore no one cares
at all when a liberal calls you a racist
you know you've won the argument it's
just it has no effect in the Public
Square it used to be the worst thing you
could possibly be called now I think
it's really losing steam because it's so
silly so so they have to up the the ante
and so that the new one is white
nationalist he's a what but
I I don't see even if I'm being as
charitable as I possibly can to the
left-wing point of view
I don't see how you could possibly
describe I don't I I don't I can't even
make fun of it I don't even know what
this guy would be talking about to call
Elon Musk a white nationalist so that's
just completely meaningless
and then then what's the second Church
what's this rich person you're just
selling out Matt Tybee for the rich
person this was a comment that was also
underlined by NBC's Ben Collins who says
imagine Throwing It All Away to do PR
work for the richest person in the world
humiliating s-h-i-t
who who do these people work for
who does Ben Collins work for that Ben
Collins does he work for the Little
Sisters of the Poor that's who he does
what is he no he gets his check from NBC
Universal a very very rich powerful
company
and he gets his check from the all these
guys watch Ali all the rest of them they
get their checks they get their funding
they at the very least they serve the
interests of
people who collectively are much much
richer than Elon Musk Elon Musk is very
rich he's one guy
the people who run NBC just like just GE
right or just any of these corporations
that own the media companies
and think about the water that these
even the so-called independent
journalists carry for the wealthiest
people on Earth for people like George
Soros the largest donor to Democrat
causes in the country
it's it's just preposterous
PR doing PR work for the richest person
in the world
all journalism
has a little touch of PR to it because
all journalism has spin because all
journalism has a perspective because the
only people who go into journalism are
people who have perspectives about
things and frankly everybody has a kind
of perspective about things because
we're rational creatures and we have
moral judgment so obviously that's the
case and when we talk about journalism
journalism is very expensive it's funded
by people it's funded by people for a
reason to advance a certain view of the
world
daily wire we put I mean we're we're
self-funded in the sense that we've run
our business from basic almost from day
one you know from about a year and a
half in on cash and we've done it
because of you well why do we why do we
do it because of you because we all
share a sort of view of the world and we
share some basic principles like a
country should have borders kids should
not have their genitals chopped off
babies shouldn't be killed in the womb
many other points of view that we all
share together and then you are willing
to spend your money to help us get the
message out there and and when we're
talking about the corporate media you've
got corporations spending a ton of money
on media because they know that it's
important to have a Bullhorn in public
so they're all to some degree
PR people they're all to some degree
propagandists the question is on behalf
of whom and on behalf of what and when I
see these guys NBC and wajahat Ali and
all the rest of them just whining and
pulling their hair out over the
publication of this story it should ask
you it should it was should expose I
think quite clearly who's really serving
the powerful entrenched interests you
have the entire corporate media and the
entire liberal establishment on one side
trying to suppress this story
and then you've got
one journalist and one rich guy on the
other side exposing it
a rich guy who is so incensed by this
kind of behavior that he spent 44
billion dollars to expose it so money
well spent especially
especially since it's not it's not my
money uh Trump was shocked and appalled
at this expose as he well should have
been and so he's gone so far as to say
that this sort of behavior allows for
the suspension of the Constitution
very trumpian kind of dialogue he says
so with the revelation of massive and
widespread fraud and deception in
working closely with big tech companies
the DNC and the Democrat Party do you
throw the presidential election results
of 2020 out and declare the rightful
winner or do you have a new election a
massive fraud of this type and magnitude
allows for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles
even those found in the Constitution our
great Founders did not want and would
not condone false and fraudulent
elections
I love the way that Trump negotiates
because he says look now that we know we
know what do you do do you either
immediately reinstate me as president or
do you immediately hold a new election
and so there's no third option there's
no third option of just Biden get to
continue to be president and we just all
move on no no that's not either he's
always talking you past the sale it's
like a guy who says hey hey I can borrow
20 bucks
he's already just begun with the premise
that he was he was trying to argue so he
says what are we going to do we've got
two options we can either re reinstate
me as president immediately or hold a
snap election immediately and then
here's the line that's got him in
trouble he says a massive fraud of this
type and magnitude allows for the
termination of all rules regulations or
articles even those found in the
Constitution
what is he saying here well it depends
on what the meaning of the word allows
allows which is if he means allows as in
prescribes the suspension of the
Constitution that's a radical statement
and all of the libs and the Never
trumpers are going to pull their hair
out over it but if the word allows
describes what has happened here
then I don't see how you could really
disagree with it meaning
they rigged the election the libs have
rigged the election they've they've
rigged the Public Square or they've
rigged the mechanism of government in a
self-governing republic
therefore we are justified in going
further and suspending the Constitution
that's a radical claim
but isn't it merely descriptive the libs
have rigged the whole system
successfully the libs were able to
dominate the Public Square and kick out
dissenting voices and cover up anything
that according to polls would have
thrown the election to to Donald Trump
again I don't really believe polls and I
think most statistics are made up but
that's what you see
12 of Biden voters according to a poll
right after the election say they would
have voted for Trump had they known
about the hunter Biden laptop story
so if the libs have already rigged all
that and gained the whole system
then haven't the rules of the
Constitution already been suspended
and we're talking about the state
constitution in Pennsylvania they were
suspended before the 2020 presidential
election that's how Pennsylvania got
widespread mail-in ballots
furthermore when Trump goes on and he
says this is not what the founders
wanted and they would not have condoned
this that's obviously true
now of course the meaning of
Constitution has changed dramatically
over time
this is one issue with conservatives and
I think it's just kind of part of our
character we are always fighting
yesterday's War I talk about this on the
show a lot
our government is not run with the bill
up on Capitol Hill
the thing you learned in civics class
for those of you who are old enough to
have had civics class that's not the way
our government is actually run and so
you have conservatives especially you
saw this in the Tea Party Movement say
well according to the Constitution that
we shouldn't have the administrative
State according to the Constitution I
don't see any mention of the Federal
Reserve System according to the
Constitution I don't see and they
describe the difference between America
in the late 18th century in America in
the early 21st century and they say
these things are totally different yeah
that's true but the Constitution has
changed over time I mean just just with
the 14th Amendment and the way the 14th
amendment was interpreted in the 20th
century you see something like the
incorporation Doctrine the idea that the
Bill of Rights would be incorporated to
the states previously the Bill of Rights
was only understood to apply to the
federal government the federal
government can't establish a church the
Federal Government Can violate Free
Speech but the states were totally
allowed to do that in fact at the time
of the ratification one of the reasons
the federal government couldn't
establish a church is because multiple
States already had established churches
so when you incorporate the Bill of
Rights into the states
that's a major change to our
constitution when you see the expansion
the well the the 17th Amendment which
says that you're going to directly elect
Senators that basically takes states
rights off the table so that's a major
change to our constitution when you see
the the Civil Rights Act and the Great
Society and the programs well first the
New Deal programs in the 1930s then
Civil Rights Act in the Great Society in
the 1960s that both of those are major
major changes to our constitution
especially the latter which creates in
many ways a new legal regime a new a new
constitutional framework in our country
this was the argument of Chris
Caldwell's book uh the age of
entitlement so obviously that's all true
and so the question for conservatives is
are we going to keep whining about the
the difference between the Constitution
as we see it on paper written at the end
of the 18th century and the present or
are we going to accept the actual
Constitution the way that our laws are
actually made and then work against that
system and fight it and win you're
seeing this in the Elon Musk case right
we could either conservatives could keep
whining about how we're being censored
on Twitter or we can get some our own
rich guy to go in and buy Twitter and
then expose it and then try to fight the
system from within are we going to keep
fighting yesterday's War are we going to
fight the war being waged on us right
now
[Music]
speaking of wars and constitutions Iran
has has disbanded its morality police
this is the big headline here so there
have been protests in Iran for a while
now this was over uh the killing of uh
woman Masa amini
who who was detained by the morality
police because she she broke the head
scarf rules she was she was walking out
without a headscarf and then she died in
custody and there have been uh protests
that that were sparked since her death
and now
the regime seems to be afraid of the
protests enough that they're saying okay
we're going to disband the morality
police that special police segment that
goes around telling people to put their
headscarves back on
what's most interesting the the story I
don't find interesting at all the
reaction to the story is what I find
very interesting
the protesters in Iran are saying this
is not good enough we are not going to
stop protesting they are pledging to
continue the demonstrations
and the reason that they are reacting
that way is the same reason
that the Iranian regime was willing to
to abolish the morality police in the
first place which is it's a completely
empty gesture
it doesn't mean anything
a regime that remains in power
cannot
abolish the morality police
because all police are the morality
police
sure maybe Iran well
let me let me rephrase that maybe Iran
more on that in a minute maybe Iran has
a special division called the morality
police but all the police are always the
morality police because all regimes have
a moral view of the world and they
encode that moral view in their laws and
then the police seek to enforce those
laws
so the protesters know it's BS they know
it's just a way to give a fake
concession and try to disband the
protests
the regime knows it's BS you've still
got the mullers in charge how on Earth
are you going to disband the morality
police and the only people who seem not
to really get it
or westerners who who misunderstand the
role of morality in politics and who
recite stupid platitudes such as you
can't legislate morality
that has never been true that is not
true today both sides of the of the
conflict right now in Iran understand
that and we would do well to understand
that too Americans would do a lot better
in American conservatives would do a lot
better if we understood there is no way
not to enforce morality the only
question is which morality are you going
to enforce I mentioned the Iran thing
Iran I'm sorry I keep screwing it up
myself there's a big debate over how do
you pronounce that the name of that
country is it Iran or Iran and I took a
Twitter poll and there were a number of
people who ran into me they said no
Michael it's pronounced Iran Iran you
know like the way Obama pronounces it
the way all the sophisticated lib
spreads Iran even the way I've been
pronouncing it because I've been hearing
it on TV for the last 20 years Iran
because that's the way that the Iranians
themselves pronounce it but I think okay
my family's Italian but when I'm
referring to Italy on the show do I say
you know a few years ago I was I was
traveling to Italia I was I was just
walking through La Republica Italiana
and then I said do I I don't do that
when I discuss the country that is
immediately to our South do I say I
think you know we're going to go on a
little trip me and sweet little Elise
we're gonna go down to Texas and then
we're gonna go down to the Rio Grande
Valley and then I think we're going to
venture into Mexico
no I don't do that I call it Mexico
because I speak English I call it Italy
because I speak English and I think we
should all call it Iran because we speak
English and more specifically we speak
American and it really really irritates
the libs when we call it Iran and so
that that is it I don't have any more
sophisticated or scholarly reason why I
advocate that pronunciation but I think
that is sufficient and I think we should
all all do it all police
are the morality police okay there's a
slight digression on the pronunciation
of Iran all police are the morality
police
but not all morality police or the
police
it's kind of like the square and the
rectangle
all police forces necessarily enforce
the morality but
not all of the people who enforce the
moral views of a culture are wearing
police uniforms okay
and that brings us right back to this
Twitter issue the reason this Twitter
issue matters so much is because
we allowed a handful of lunatics lunatic
leftists in Silicon Valley
to dictate the morality that would be
accepted in the Public Square and they
did so in a way that was in
contravention of morality they did so in
a way that elevated falsehood over truth
that elevated evil over good and that
elevated ugliness over Beauty that's the
problem so this guy yoel Roth who is the
former Twitter safety chief
he was filmed on
on stage at some stupid lib conference
discussing how
The Babylon bee
and Libs of tick tock two of the
funniest accounts on Twitter
could kill people
okay Babylon B which is what got him to
buy the thing I think that's the that's
right the one which is which was not
particularly funny The Babylon bees man
of the year is Rachel Levine
not funny yeah
um and and you can I didn't agree they
should have taken that down but go ahead
you know it's interesting uh it's
interesting thing about what the
competing tensions around that are and I
want to start by acknowledging that um
the targeting and the victimization of
the trans community on Twitter is very
real very life-threatening and
extraordinarily serious
um we have seen from a number of Twitter
accounts including Libs of tick tock
notably that there are orchestrated
campaigns that particularly are singling
out a group that is already particularly
vulnerable within society and so yeah
not only is it not funny but it is
dangerous and it does contribute to an
environment that makes people unsafe in
the world
when the Babylon Bee makes a joke
about how a man is not a woman that
kills people okay that kills people and
that's why we need to
de-platform The Babylon bee and lives of
tick tock when Libs of tick tock
do the work that journalists pretend
that they do
and when Libs of tick tock exposes
abuses and Corruption and child abuse
uh that is killing people and so we need
to kick her out of the Public Square
this is the fatwa handed down by the
American mullers those two people on
stage those are the American mullahs
there are many others as well
sitting there in their chairs with their
microphones
just like the supreme leader of Iran
issuing the the moral declarations by
which we all must live and they have the
power to enforce them or at least they
did until Elon came in and booted these
people out
but they they do they largely have the
power to enforce this stuff at Facebook
at Google at Twitter and in many other
areas of power as well but it's so
noticeable there because they control
the Public Square they control the
speech in the country they say we will
not now tolerate
we will not now tolerate anyone
suggesting that a man cannot be a woman
we will they're fixing their turbans as
they say this we will not tell this is
the fatwa issue supreme leader
Twitter's safety and policy board
oh all hail the Twitter safety and
policy board
Americans
we make fun of the malas in Iran we make
fun of the Iranian form of government
can you believe these men so divorced
from the modern world
so divorce from reality are going to
issue these declarations and make these
women put on head coverings
at least they're not telling kids to
chop their genitals off
okay I think before we start casting
Stones there are a lot of criticisms to
make of the Iranian regime but maybe
before we start casting Stones how about
we
take a look in the mirror okay before we
accuse them how about we take a look at
ourselves because that that that is how
the United States is run
we are run by a an elite largely
unaccountable self-appointed morality
police who have the ability to enforce
their liberal fatwas
okay and in some cases their view of
morality is far more perverse
than the view of our enemies around the
world
speaking of laughing and the ruling
class speaking of mocking these sorts of
things
Barack Obama just
just said something very interesting and
I I almost have never said that I never
thought Barack Obama was a particularly
interesting public speaker I know when
he came on the scene in 2008 people said
he was the greatest order since Pericles
I never saw that I just thought he said
empty platitudes in a largely boring way
his most famous speech was there's not a
red America not a blue America not a
States of America not a Black America
not a white America it's not and you
just think okay okay this is
this is the most banal kind of
platitudeness thing I've ever heard in
my life but he at least
has presented himself as this great
speaker and he does always choose his
words carefully and while campaigning
for Raphael Warnock he took a shot
and Uncle Joe
oh no some folks in our lives
who we don't wish them ill will
they say crazy stuff we're all like well
you know Uncle Joe you know what
happened to him
you know it's okay
they're part of the family
but you don't
give him serious responsibilities
uh he's talking about crazy Uncle Joe
that's a little awkward and the way that
Liberals are reacting to this is to say
oh come on give me a break he wasn't
talking about Joe Biden
he was talking no he was just saying you
know he was just using crazy Uncle Joe
to mean you know whoever you're you're a
random Uncle I'm not he's not talking
about Joe Biden
I'm not convinced of that whatever you
want to say about Barack Obama I have
plenty of mean things that I could say
about Barack Obama the man generally
does not misspeak
in fact as crazy Uncle Joe said during
the 2008 primaries Barack Obama is very
articulate I think I think it was Joe
Biden who said that Barack Obama was the
first clean articulate black man in
American politics okay so so you can
take Joe's words for it too crazy Uncle
Joe Barack Obama is precise about his
diction
I I think if for anyone who is paying
attention this was a clear shot at Joe
Biden because in recent weeks you've
seen Joe Biden signaling he does not
want to get out of the way in 2024 that
he does want to run again
a lot of Democrats don't want him to run
again and so what does Barack Obama do
in this thinly veiled Barb he says you
know when you got crazy Uncle Joe Uncle
Joe is Joe Biden's nickname when you got
crazy Uncle Joe you don't you're nice to
him you know he's in the family but you
don't give him a lot of responsibilities
you don't do that
insinuating perhaps that Joe Biden
doesn't have a lot of responsibilities
now he's just being sort of LED around
by the hand and certainly I think
implying that Joe Biden should not have
a lot of responsibilities come 2024. so
who is running the show
who will be the titular head in 2024
but even now if Joe Biden doesn't have a
lot of responsibilities who's running
the show
who is actually enforcing enforcing our
morality who are the morality police
who is the executive in the United
States is Barack Obama seems to suggest
it ain't the president the holidays are
officially here everybody
many of you are already daily wire Plus
members and you get to enjoy the great
content
that we have released this year such as
what is a woman and greatest lie ever
sold
if you haven't been able to enjoy it
because you're not a member
take advantage of our 30 holiday sale
this also applies to gift membership so
do not miss the opportunity to get
everyone on your list an annual gift
membership
from daily wire plus with code holiday
at checkout since joining daily wire
plus Jordan Peterson has ramped up his
already busy schedule we have been
reaping the rewards earlier this year
Jordan went to Washington DC to film a
beautiful and engaging documentary on
the Museum of the Bible called logos and
literacy in it Jordan meets with
historians theologians and philosophers
to discuss the history of the Bible and
its influence on the world Jordan was so
happy with it he actually watched it
twice no doubt you will want to do the
same but the only way you can do it is
if you're a daily wire plus member so
sign up today use code holiday at
checkout to get 30 off your new annual
daily wire plus membership at
dailywire.com Knowles that is
dailywire.com Knowles today
speaking of incompetence in our federal
government really great news everybody
you can breathe a sigh of relief
the Department of Health and Human
Services has declared an end to the
monkey pox emergency I know you were all
quaking in your boots you were so
nervous about the spread of monkey pox
but it's over
well actually monkey pox is is not over
because they don't call it that anymore
according to Xavier Becerra the
Secretary of HHS from the outset of the
M pox outbreak the administration pulled
every lever to stop the spread of this
virus so it's m pox now because monkey
pox is offensive for some reason I'm not
sure what is offensive about it I don't
think they've renamed the chickenpox I
don't think it's the sea pox I don't so
I don't know why that is
some people said it had a stigma because
the virus comes from Africa before the
weird gay fetish orgies in Belgium and
Spain spread it around the world monkey
box is pretty much contained just in
Zaire
or if there were stigma
because it pretty much only spread with
promiscuous homosexual men so if it
seemed like someone was comparing them
to monkeys I don't know but anyway
monkey box you're not allowed to say it
anymore it's m pox and that's not even
the craziest thing that Becerra said in
his statement he said the administration
pulled every lever to stop the spread of
the virus that just isn't true
the administration did not do that
it would be very simple to stop the
spread of monkey box it would have been
very simple to stop it much faster than
it already was it was always going to be
a more contained sort of thing because
it only really statistically affected
one group of people a relatively small
group of people and it was contained
pretty much to just the the cities and
because there were vaccines out there
that were somewhat effective
in slowing the spread which for instance
you didn't have with HIV in the in the
80s and 90s as I was always going to be
contained but they could have contained
it a lot faster and they could have
contained about being honest and just
saying
no monkey pox doesn't spread to
everybody no as we heard from the
administration at the beginning this is
not everyone's equally at risk here and
potentially going to contract monkey box
pretty much the only way you get it is
if you're a very promiscuous homosexual
man
not even if you're just a relatively
mild homosexual man who has none or one
sexual partner there you're not going to
get monkey bucks but if you go to the
bath houses and you go to The Fetish
parties in Belgium and Spain and later
then in New York and San Francisco and
all over the place and you have sex with
multiple partners in a very short period
of time you are much more likely to
contract monkey bucks so stop doing that
the administration couldn't say that
because that would be considered
homophobic today
to tell a basic truth I have gay friends
who are more reasonable than than the
libs which is you know not saying all
that much but you know I'm these are
these are sensible people who would come
out and they because I would ask I'd say
am I am I do I sound homophobic do I
sound big they say Michael
they should rename it gay orgy pox that
would get the message out very very
clearly the Biden Administration didn't
want to do that because at every single
turn they seem
so concerned with hiding the truth
you see it on Twitter you see it in the
statements of the administration on
public health and all and everything in
between they want to hide the truth
because the truth does not go very well
with their narrative speaking of
scientific truth there is a scientist
who worked at the Wuhan Laboratory
who is now coming out
and admitting that the Wuhan
virus was a lab leak
this is his opinion this is his his
bombshell I think it was it was reported
in the Sun out of the UK
this is Andrew Huff
Andrew Huff not only worked at the Wuhan
Institute of virology
he worked for Eco Health Alliance Eco
Health Alliance is if you've seen my
documentary on Dr fauci which is
available at Daily wire Plus
uh Eco Health Alliance is the
organization Peter dashak
Peter daschak recklessly pursuing gain
of function research recklessly working
with the Wuhan Institute of virology on
that coronaviruses this was covered up
by the government
Dr fauci lied about this in front of the
Senate then it turned out it was true
the NIH actually had funded this
organization had been funding sub-brands
to the Wuhan Institute of virology well
this guy Andrew Huff who worked at Eco
Health from 2014 to 2016 says that the
Eco Health helped the Wuhan lab put
together quote the best existing methods
to engineer bat coronaviruses to attack
other species for many years Huff says
China knew from day one that this was a
genetically engineered agent
the U.S government is to blame for the
transfer of dangerous biotechnology to
the Chinese I was terrified by what I
saw he says we were just handing them
bio weapon technology
and I suspect this is behind a lot of
the cover-ups a lot of the we don't want
Hunter Biden's laptop getting out a lot
of this is a threat to safety a lot of
the we've got to accuse Trump of
colluding with the Russians we've got to
wield the federal government to to stop
Trump's campaign kill it in the Cradle
what is it all about is it about them
fearing their the conservative policies
yes that's part of it but I think
another part of it maybe an even deeper
part of it
is that the libs don't want their
screw-ups and Corruption exposed
they knew that if Donald Trump had been
elected president
that it would come out that the Obama
Administration was wielding the
government against the Republicans
against their political enemies that the
Obama Administration was was wielding
the government to spy on Donald Trump's
campaign and that did come out so all of
a sudden
the the political operation to stop
Trump because you don't like his
policies
becomes a little bit of a cya operation
shoot now we have to succeed here
because otherwise he's going to cover up
he's going to uncover our corruption
a lot of the the tamping down of of
dissent when it comes to coronavirus the
the basic questions people were asking
where did this virus come from it was
not man-made this had nothing to do with
the Wuhan
uary virology we
funded gain of fund and [ __ ] research
we do not fund the Wuhan Institute none
of that ever all of that was a lie all
of that was was fed why because Dr
fauci's just so ignorant because he's so
forgetful
no because he was trying to cover up his
actions that as Andrew Huff is
suggesting here contributed
to the creation of the Coronavirus
and so that becomes a self-fulfilling
cycle it becomes a self-perpetuating
cycle
you've got all this lib corruption from
these people who have held onto power
for far too long
and so they're raison Detra becomes
continuing to cover up their corruption
which is in itself corrupt and so you
get an Ever tightening grip on power
they can't let go even a little bit
because it will expose just how corrupt
they have been
now speaking of
things that happened a long time ago
that people are trying to cover up Anna
Navarro on The View
is attacking the uh Cowboys owner Jerry
Jones she wants answers okay she's going
after the real stories
it's not about
the Twitter corruption not about the
Biden Administration corruption not
about no just go after the real stories
uh when Jerry Jones was 14 he's 80 years
old now by the way when Jerry Jones was
14
he was photographed near a rally about
segregation
LeBron James gave an interview
um or maybe it was Wednesday without I
thought was so incredibly poignant where
he brought up the picture from 1957 of
Jerry Jones the owner of the of the
Dallas Cowboys
um standing in Arkansas as a mob of
white boys were blocking black students
from going into a high school and you
know and LeBron made the point that
he gets all these questions about Kyrie
Irving about everybody else about all
these things and he said you know you
guys haven't asked me about Kyrie Irving
about Jerry Jones and why the disparate
attention and I do think it's important
and I hope that Jerry Jones who has so
many black players who has such a
platform who has all this money who's
got all this access I hope Jerry Jones
really does take the opportunity to to
own this to talk about it to explain it
and to talk about the change that has
happened in 65 years and his role and
how he claims he was just a casual
Observer at that and and yeah he was 14
he was a casual Observer 14 year old
right
the best part of it is sunny who who
acknowledges she has to admit here look
maybe he was just there there was a
crowd of people watching something maybe
he was so maybe he was a casual Observer
and also he was 14. he was a child he
was in what ninth or eighth grade or
ninth grade
but there were 14 year olds in the KKK
are there maybe okay maybe
the conservatives must be
the most virtuous people the American
conservatives in the year 2022. must be
some of the most virtuous people ever to
walk the earth
if this is the best the Democrats can do
if the if the best that the Democrats
can do to come up with a scandal about
American conservatives is that
66 years ago
the Dallas Cowboys owner when he was in
ninth grade
was in a crowd of people watching
an event about set desegregation
if that's the best they've got they
don't have anything that they can point
to that they can complain about any time
in the intervening 66 years man we must
be doing something right because I can
point to Democrat corruption right now
that's going on right now in a really
really egregious way that is causing all
sorts of problems that is causing deaths
in some cases when we're talking about
the covid lockdown regime all sorts of
other problems and the best they've got
and this is true this isn't just about
Jerry Jones this is all they ever talk
about well you know they're Jim Crow
there was Jim Crow there was Jim when
was Jim Crow oh my gosh man was it 70
years ago yeah and that's why you need
to give us all this power now and we
need to kick you out of the Public
Square because there was slavery there
was when was slavery that was 150 years
ago that's the best you've got
okay keep keep talking about all the
problems from over a century ago we're
going to keep pointing out the the awful
things that you're doing right in the
here and now we'll see who the people
side with we know who the people will
side with that's why they got to rig the
system that's why they feel that they've
got to rig the system because if the
Democrats felt that they could win fair
and square they wouldn't have to rig the
Public Square and they wouldn't have to
change all of the election rules in
contravention of state constitutions in
some cases you know the rest of the show
continues now all right and this is a
music Monday baby
I told the guys I said no more rap okay
we've done enough rap let's hold off on
the wrap for a little bit or I've had
I've had enough
so they're they're going to take me back
to the 90s they're going to take me back
to the 90s and early 2000s by playing a
little alternative rock okay so I'm
gonna bleach my tips in between now and
the members block I'm going to get out
some nice Quicksilver and Billabong
clothing throw out throw out a
skateboard and meet you guys over at the
member block if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]